hey guys Dave and Anna again I wanted to
talk a little bit about this whole plane
situation which is obviously horrible as
we're taping it right now it is still
missing seemingly nobody knows what's
going on we are news people right I like
we think so we like to think there were
news people the big story to me since we
don't know what's going on the plane is
how bad the news coverage has been
particularly CNN is 24-hour endless
speculation where they start every
sentence by saying we're not going to
speculate and then they spend in
speculate and they bring on a panel
literally of like six guests at once and
two hosts and cameras flying in and out
and just this horrible sensation
Elisabet sensationalism of it easier
said what do you make of a media
coverage because to me that's bit look
the plane itself obviously terrible and
there's only so much we can say about it
while we don't know what's going on but
to this idea that the the news can't
stop and can't control itself yeah so
the reason why like some of the major
networks like CNN cover the missing
Malaysia flight 24 hours a day is
because it's obviously helping them with
their ratings and so I don't know if it
speaks it doesn't speak highly of our
media or if it doesn't speak highly of
the American people because these are
the people that are consuming the news
these are the people were watching and
no matter what you want to believe about
a particular network at the end of the
day what they care about is how much
money they make and how much advertisers
or how many advertisers they can bring
in through their cut their coverage so
so there's a little issue there however
I don't think that that's enough of an
excuse for a network to do irresponsible
speculation on a really really important
and tragic story yeah so it's a little
bit of chicken or the egg because they
keep feeding it to us and then we keep
watching and then we complain about it
but then that only spikes the ratings
even more um how do they get out of it
how do they stop now they've come so far
right we're 14 days in or something it
can CNN tomorrow be like you know what
we realized we didn't know what we were
doing to these last two weeks back to
back to the normal news well CNN can go
and experiment with their coverage and
instead of going to the lowest common
denominator and doing speculation they
can do unique coverage on issues that
you don't see in the mainstream press
right so on tyt we've covered the
malaysia flight a little bit but we only
do so when there's new information and
we try to avoid speculating as much as
possible um you know some people have
their hypothesis and I guess it's okay
to share what you think but it's
important to say look this is just
speculation we don't know but the reason
why to whiteys popular is because we
cover that people want to hear
stuff that you're not going to see in
other news networks vice does the same
thing so does that also show you why the
the internet is the future because CNN
has to put something out for 24 hours
just endless crap they have to keep
talking where what we do you can click
away we hope you don't but you can click
away and you can choose what to watch
exactly you can pick and choose which is
awesome and you look at the title of
video and you're Layton I'm not really
into that story instead I'm gonna focus
on this story regarding I don't know
income inequality yeah pulling it off
off the top of my head so yeah I think I
think this whole notion that there needs
to be 24 our live coverage is a very
antiquated one and I like that new media
is kind of changing the model changing
the mold and the majority of Millennials
which by the way these major networks
want to appeal to don't consume their
news that way they don't run home to
watch a live show they'll they'll tivo
yes but a lot of times they want content
on demand on the Internet yeah the other
thing I think is that if you feed people
constantly they will keep consuming
it as gross as that sounds you're doing
me like they just keep feeding it to us
and then people just keep watching it's
like we have somehow we have to make
them better I know and I mean us as
people that are in the online news world
like we got to do it because they're
handing us a pretty good gift here don't
they really are and it's always funny to
me when they want to appeal to an
audience and the way that they do it is
by like doing ridiculous sensationalism
that people can see through right away
so you know what CNN you do you I love
it cuz we're snatching up your audience
literally very odd you watch
people up in here we're coming for you
wolf blitzer you hear me subscribe we
want to know what you guys think let us
know in the comments down below
subscribe what else can they do on
YouTube you can comment you can comment
leave if you're nice only nice comments
please thank you